io sono qui per dare i numeri e per
parlare della fine della scuola come la
conosciamo
fino ad adesso il primo numero è 78 che
è il voto medio di maturità degli
studenti del liceo scientifico di
lussana di bergamo che si sono diplomati
con il metodo impara digitale ogni
mattina entrano in classe si dividono in
gruppi e sostanzialmente creano un ebook
sull'argomento che stanno studiando un
esempio stanno facendo la rivoluzione
francese
un gruppo fa l'assemblea della
pallacorda l'altro fa la presa della
bastiglia cosa usano non usano un solo
libro di testo usano decine di fonti sia
cartacea sia digitali grazie i loro
tablet assemblano tutto quanto poi ogni
studente dal proprio ebook l'ebook del
proprio gruppo agli altri gruppi tutti
gli studenti dopo aver lavorato in modo
collaborativo studiano anche il lavoro
dei propri compagni di classe
poi l'insegnante che gli aiutati in
questo delicato complesso compito arriva
e si sa che interroga cosa succede
funzionava e funziona lo vediamo dal dal
voto medio di maturità è finita la
pacchia lo studente noi studenti non
possiamo più stare a a cincischiare a
farci cavoli nostri l'ultima fila
l'intero percorso formativo diventa
attivo devi creare e se per caso e
l'influenza nessun problema sotto il tuo
piumone da casa
puoi seguire e partecipare col tuo
tablet attivamente alla lezione in
questo modo gli studenti non imparano
solo la la presa della bastiglia
imparano anche a a vivere da cittadini
di internet cioè ad avere a che fare con
ogni giorno decine se non centinaia di
flussi input bisogna avere un po di
senso critico
la tecnologia non fa mai la differenza
da sola vediamo in questo caso la fanno
il metodo è sostanzialmente gli
insegnanti 203 milioni mentre parlo
proprio adesso il contatore delle
lezioni di khan academy il sito creato
da un geniale trentenne indiano salman
khan è arrivato a 203 milioni di video
lezioni erogate gratuitamente a persone
in qualsiasi paese della terra
e in qualsiasi ora della giornata cioè
questa sì che è una nuova età dell'oro
ha un'età dell'oro in cui una mattina
qualcuno si sveglia un'idea culturali la
realizza e quest'idea poveri impatti su
centinaia di milioni di persone
vi consiglio di andare a vedere il sito
vediamo che diamo i numeri qui abbiamo
un 14 14 è l'età che avevamo quando
abbiamo creato il project una scuola
gratuita online in cui chiunque può
insegnare al prossimo quello che sai in
un'ottica di libera condivisione delle
conoscenze da dal teorema di pitagora
l'educazione sessuale da william
shakespeare
scusate a italo calvino e a insegnare
sono sia perfetti sconosciuti persone
che si mettono davanti alla webcam e
iniziano a parlare di dolce stil novo
sia i massimi esperti italiani della
materia quindi professori esperti
giornalisti professionisti
tutto questo per condividere le proprie
conoscenze chi giudica le elezioni è la
community con i voti e col buon senso
che non sbaglia mai
altro che come comitato scientifico
vediamo qualcosa abbiamo qui abbiamo
mille che è il numero di ore effettive
di formazione gratuita erogati dal
project ieri 27 27 sono gli euro che
sono serviti nel 2004 per creare il
project 27 euro che sono circa 21
cappuccini senza né kakà one e cannella
poi abbiamo 22 che sono adesso ne
parlava prima sono i divani del mio
soggiorno
il soggiorno da qui in dieci persone
facciamo o il project e gli italiani che
negli ultimi 12 mesi hanno visto almeno
una lezione suoi project sia in diretta
se in differita
ripeto su qualsiasi argomento la
letteratura alla chimica sono 250.000 la
scuola che sogniamo noi non costa nulla
prenderà ci sia da torino sia da enna
anche alle 3 del mattino è una scuola
che corre la tua velocità perché sei tu
a decidere di cosa parlare ea risponde
alle domande non sono solo i docenti
anche docenti sono anche i compagni di
banco la scuola che abbiamo vinte noi è
una condizione mentale una condizione
mentale come quelle cose che a un primo
sguardo
tipo radice di meno uno ti sembra una
follia poi a un certo punto una una
soluzione la si trova sempre
cosa andrà online andranno online
le lezioni frontali andranno online le
lezioni che gli insegnanti di anno in
anno a prescindere dalla classe che
hanno davanti fanno uguali quelle
andranno online andrà online il lavoro
collaborativo tra studenti in modalità
wiki e finalmente nelle classi fisiche
rimarrà il tempo per fare quello che non
abbiamo mai avuto il tempo di fare e
cioè le discussioni e il confronto tra
gli studenti come fanno a bergamo con
impara digitale il confronto tra gli
autori che che studiamo i ragionamenti
perché per fare un ponte servono i
numeri complessi come ci si orienta nel
marasma nell information overload
internet che cos'è questa questa
assonanza che che io lettore sento ad
esempio fra confronto tra autori tra
kafka buzzati che cos'è ecco io non so
come sarà la scuola del futuro perché
appunto come vi dicevo prima faccio siti
web e non oroscopi quindi non
esattamente non lo so però so che c'è da
sperimentare moltissimo da lavorare
tantissimo e che nulla succede per caso
gli imprevisti vanno concordati in
anticipo e non dobbiamo avere nessun
tipo di pregiudizio perché quando
l'unico strumento di cui si dispone è un
martello tutto tenderà ad assomigliare a
un chiodo
quindi stiamo attenti grazie mille buona
serata a tutti